who would win do you think in a fight
between you and tom holland
oh that's not a challenging question
that's actually a very easy question it
would be uh
hey i'm mark wahlberg and i'm going to
be answering questions from the lab
bible staff
everyone rolling yeah hey guys nice to
meet you how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm doing good i have a question for you
what was your first ever job well my
first job was probably shoveling snow
uh cleaning up and then i was selling
newspapers i had many many jobs over the
years very nice to meet you thank you
what's happening mark so i wanna know
what's your favorite british slang word
i can't say my favorite slang word on tv
because uh
i don't think it's uh politically
correct anymore but geezer i love geezer
joy to teach you up sure give me
something
my favorite one where i'm from is heavy
if a girl's good looking
you'll say oh yeah she's heavier oh yeah
if you do that in america you might get
a little slap
[Laughter]
i think that'll be the way cheers mark
thank you thanks thank you for that hi
mark i'm jake i've got a challenging
question for you who would win do you
think in a fight between you and tom
holland
oh that's not a challenging question
that's actually a very easy question it
would be uh
yes but no you know what tom tom uh i
would rather have tom as an ally than an
enemy he's uh he's a good man
me
mark walbo that's actually a really nice
picture of me and that's not very
flattering light on mark there i think
i'm gonna win this one
any words for mark that's pretty brutal
hey mark lovely to meet you i'm amy
hi amy how are you my question for you
is what is your best party trick
my best party trick uh you know i just
just being a storyteller what's your
party trick i can dance for hours on end
i go out on friday and not come home
until monday that's the party truth are
you still dancing yeah
oh my gosh you'll feel free
but i'll pass you on now did they just
try to get you to dance
how's it going
hey mark i'm layla so i have a question
for you who is the funniest co-star you
have ever worked with wow that's
actually that's easy i would i you could
say ted but that's the voice of seth
macfarlane but will farrell because he's
also the sweetest and kindest uh person
i've ever worked and i just well i just
work with kevin hart too so he's he's
right up there but i haven't worked with
will
three times i would have to give it to
will because every time i see him he
still just makes me laugh thank you nice
to meet you thank you nice to meet you
too hey mark
hello mark i'm dean nice to meet you hey
dean how are you i'm good thanks so i've
got one question for you when you bulk
up for your next action film i was
wondering if you have any like cheeky
cheat days where you go from mackies or
maybe even a cheeky nandos oh oh gosh
nando's that's the chicken spot right
that's not a cheat meal i eat jolly
nando's three times a day you know it
really depends i'm like sometimes i'll
just start craving something it usually
be like pancakes or something breakfast
bacon egg sausage
you know toast that sort of thing do you
have any recommendations for like a good
pancake place in the states ihop
international house of pancakes it's a
chain it's fantastic cheers thanks
hi
okay last ques last question mark last
question oh sorry about guys in the back
hi
hi
hi
sorry about that hi i'm eliza nice to
meet you
my question is what's the best memento
you've ever taken from a film
well i know this is a bit of a risque
answer but i did a movie called boogie
nights quite a while ago that had uh
some unique uh props that i kept it's
probably the only time i've ever kept a
prop from a movie but i felt it was such
a personal intimate thing that i needed
to keep it
sorry i didn't get to talk to you guys
in the back hi
next time promoting a movie director
make sure i only talk to those girls
they're first in line next time they're
first in line next time
just to let you know that one person did
say naked attraction really yeah well
that's obviously my biggest fan
what is naked attraction
oh it's that show dirty